how do you describe rotation in three
dimensions so for example I have here a
globe and it's rotating in some way and
there's a certain direction that it's
rotating a speed with which it's
rotating and the question is how could
you give me some numerical information
that perfectly describes that rotation
so you give me some numbers and I can
tell you the speed in the direction and
everything associated with this rotation
well before talking about that let's
remind ourselves of how we talk about
two-dimensional rotation so I have here
a little pie creature and I set them to
start rotating about and the way that we
can describe this we pretty much need to
just give a rate to it and you might
give that rate as a number of rotations
number of rotations per second some unit
of time so rotations per second and in
this case I think I programmed him so
that he's going to do one rotation for
every five seconds so his rotational
rate would be zero point two but that's
a little bit ambiguous because if you
just say hey this little pie creature is
rotating at zero point two rotations per
second someone could say well is it
clockwise or counter clockwise so
there's some ambiguity and the
convention that people have adopted is
to say well if I give you a positive
number if the number is positive then
that's going to tell you that the nature
of the rotation is counterclockwise but
if I give you a negative number if
instead you see something that's a
negative number of rotations per second
that would be rotation the other way
going clockwise and that's the
convention that's just what people have
decided on and with this it's very nice
because given a single number just one
number and it could be positive or
negative
you can perfectly describe
two-dimensional rotation and there's a
minor nuance here usually in physics and
math we don't actually use rotations per
unit second but instead you describe
things in terms of the number of radians
per unit second radians and just as a
quick reminder of what that means if you
can if you imagine some kind of circle
and it could be any circle the size
doesn't really matter and if you draw
the radius to that and then ask the
question how far along the circumference
would I have to go such that the the arc
length that sort of sub portion of the
circumference is exactly as long as the
radius so if this was our you'd want you
know them to know how far you have to go
before that arc length is also our
and then that that angle that amount of
turning that you can do determines one
Radian and because there's exactly two
pi radians for every rotation to convert
between you know rotations per unit
second and radians per unit second you
would just multiply this guy by 2pi so
this you know it would be whatever the
number you have there times two pi and
the specific numbers aren't too
important that the main the main upshot
here is that with a single number
positive or negative you can perfectly
describe two-dimensional rotation but if
we look over here at the 3d case there's
actually more information than just one
number that we're going to need to know
first of all you want to know the axis
around which it's rotating so the line
that you can draw such that all rotation
happens around that line and then you
want to describe the actual rate at
which it's going you know is it slow
rotation or is it fast so you need to
know a direction along with a magnitude
and you might say to yourself hey
Direction magnitude sounds like we could
use a vector and in fact that's what we
do you use some kind of vector whose
length is going to correspond to the
rate at which it's rotating typically in
radians per second it's called the
angular velocity and then the direction
describes the axis of rotation itself
but similar to how in two dimensions
there was an ambiguity between clockwise
and counterclockwise if this was the
only convention we had it would be
ambiguous whether you should use this
vector or if you should use one pointing
in the opposite direction and the way
I've chosen to draw these guys by the
way it doesn't matter where they are
remember a vector just has a magnitude
in a direction and you can put it
anywhere in space I figured it was
natural enough to just kind of put them
around the poles just so that you could
see them on the axis of rotation itself
so the question is what vector do you
use do you use the one pointing in this
direction or do you use this green one
pointing in the opposite direction and
for this we have a convention known as
the right hand rule so I'll go ahead and
bring in a picture here to illustrate
the right hand rule what you imagine
doing is taking the fingers of your
right hand and curling them around in
the direction of rotation what I mean by
that is the tips of your fingers will be
pointing kind of the direction that the
surface of the sphere would move then
when you stick out your thumb that's the
direction that is the choice of vector
which should describe that rotation so
in the specific example we have here
when you stick out your right thumb that
corresponds to the white
actor not the green one but if you did
things the other way around if you move
this a little bit so let's see get them
get them to stay in place
if you move things the other way around
such the rotation we're going kind of in
the opposite direction then when you
imagine curling the fingers of your
right hand around that direction your
thumb is going to point according to the
green vector but with the original
rotation that I that I started
illustrating it's the white vector the
white vector is the one to go with and
this is actually pretty cool right
because you're packing a lot of
information into that vector it tells
you what the axis is it tells you the
speed of rotation via its magnitude and
then the choice of which direction along
that axis tells you whether the globe is
going one way or if it's going the other
so with just three numbers the
three-dimensional coordinates of this
vector you can perfectly describe any
one given three-dimensional rotation and
the reason I'm talking about this by the
way in a series of videos about curl is
because what I'm about to talk about is
three dimensional curl which relates to
a fluid flow in three dimensions and how
that induces a rotation at every single
point in space and what's going to
happen is you're going to associate a
vector with every single point in space
to answer the question what rotation at
that point is induced by the certain
fluid flow and I'm getting a little bit
ahead of myself here for right now you
just need to focus on a single point of
rotation and a single vector
corresponding to that but it's important
to kind of get your head around how
exactly we represent this rotation with
a vector before moving on to the notably
more cognitively intensive subject of
three-dimensional curl so with that I
will see you next video